this is a bit different for a success in
booths video in that actually it's sort
of meta video in that it's not actually
about science it's about sixty symbols
itself and the exciting news is that
there is the opportunity for somebody
new to get involved in the whole project
somebody to come and join the team start
making some of the videos start doing
some science the whole point of this
series is that they're kind of bits of
science being described by scientists
and so we do want somebody who is a
professional scientist get involved in
this but what's a bit different about it
is that you'll notice most of the people
doing the videos are getting on a bit
these days we've been doing them for a
while and so what's exciting about this
is we need somebody at a much earlier
stage in the scientific career involved
in the whole project so that not only
can they talk about the science but
obviously one of the questions we get
asked quite a lot of the time is you
know what's it like to be starting out
in a career in science for us that was
all affair while ago so having somebody
who's actually going through that
process now can talk about what it's
like to be starting in a career in
science as well as talking about the
science itself is part of what we're
trying to do so it's called the sixty
symbols
Ogden fellowship it's what we've managed
to create and the different parts of
that so let's start at the backend
fellowship basically means this is a
postdoctoral researcher who can do
whatever they like so that's kind of the
distinction between just a general
postdoc and a fellow is that fellows
really dictate their own research
program so we want somebody to come in
it's got exciting ideas about what
science they want to be doing anywhere
within physics or astronomy this is a
real research position you know it's
going to be 2/3 of the time doing
research 1/3 of the time maybe doing
outreach type things but it's
fundamentally a proper research position
and a very exciting opportunity because
as I say the person who's coming in
really will get to define what their
research program is so that's the
fellowship bit the bit in the middle a
little bit the beginning is 60 symbols
that's the easy bit the bit in the
middle the Ogden bit is because
obviously this takes money and we've
been looking around trying to find
somebody to support this idea and the
Ogden trust which is a charitable trust
that kind of promotes physics in the UK
has agreed to fund partly fund the
position so part of the job will
actually be supporting the kind of the
Ogden Trust's agenda of getting out into
the community talking about physics
encouraging groups of people who don't
typically go into scientific careers to
go into scientific careers what are they
going to have to do with sixty symbols
or do we well I
so I have some saying that you'd
probably get to say a bit about that I
mean my initial idea was really that
they just stay fit in with the team so
they start making the kind of videos
that we make generally obviously they'll
bring their own particular interests so
hopefully some new areas of physics that
we haven't been covering but also to
talk more generally about what they're
up to what it's like to be doing the job
that they're doing you know when they
start applying for their own funding and
those kinds of things they can talk
about all that just talking about things
from that early career perspective that
the rest of us don't really have they'll
feature in the videos and you know if
they have particular skills they want to
bring to bear that we don't currently
use then that would be fine too so it is
a postdoctoral position which means that
one of the requirements of the post is
you have to have a PhD that's that's
really it though and so we're looking
for somebody who's probably just at the
point of completing a PhD now or
completed it in the last year or so
who's looking for their first serious
research position I want an astronomer
but that's just truth I'm an astronomer
had if you talked to Phil Moriarty he
won so you know a nice nanotechnologist
so I'm sure we all have our own idea is
exactly who the right person for the job
is that there is no there is no there is
no set person though is there there is
no real just note there's no agenda no
hidden agenda here we haven't got
somebody lined up already it's a
completely open competition when we
appointing postdoctoral researchers the
main thing we look at is you know their
CV and publication list and all those
kinds of things we're going to ask for
those those things but obviously this is
a bit different and so the other thing
we're asking people to do is to make a
video themselves no more than two
minutes duration just explaining some
piece of science they do not really not
necessarily in the style of sixty
symbols but kind of at the level of
sixty symbols so just to kind of
demonstrate they have that ability to
explain what they're doing in the kind
of way that we explain things and the
other thing to stress about that is when
we come to kind of assess those videos
we're not going to look at the technical
quality of you know assuming the video
viewable and the sounds audible and
those kinds of things we're really not
going to be critiquing them because you
know we have an entirely adequate
cameraman the position is funded for two
years so it's a two-year position
obviously we're hoping that it'll be a
huge success and everyone will be
falling all over themselves to continue
funding it but it will be guaranteed for
two years at least you know there's lots
of reasons why we're excited about this
it's a new thing with pushing the
project to new directions
it's an opportunity to do some new
science and I guess what's most exciting
about that is it's an opportunity to do
new science that wouldn't have happened
at all if it wasn't for sixty symbols so
actually the science that comes out of
this is science that wouldn't have been
done if it weren't for the sixty symbols
videos so which i think is really kind
of exciting aspect to the whole thing
yeah later
vastly restrict the amount of light
coming in to isolate exactly the
wavelengths that we want so it turns our
wide filter into a filter with a width
of just a nanometer or so and it's
tunable so it's got two little plates
inside a reflecting material